when principal the brains that is quite
distributed you can destroy any one
synapse it doesn't affect anything now
what does this apps actually look like
they're very very complicated all right
they're very small your brain is about a
liter of material and a synapse is about
a femto liter of volume so think about a
trillionth of a liter and then divide
that by a thousand and that's the femto
liter okay and so you have a quadrillion
synapses in your brain and so they
provide the scratch space that you need
by changing their size to store all of
your memories and even within that femto
liter volume you have about 40,000
proteins and those proteins do various
jobs like moving vesicles around to
release neurotransmitter being the ion
channels that control the strength or
the setups and doing all of the
housekeeping and maintenance to keep
that synapse alive and then also to be
able to change the size so very
complicated constructs but the main
takeaway is that if you're going to
create a long term memory you undergo
the process of memory consolidation and
every consolidation changes the size of
synapses and changing the size of
synapses requires protein synthesis we
know this because if you inhibit protein
synthesis
you can't consolidate memories anymore
it's actually kind of a weird effect you
can be under the effect of a protein
synthesis inhibitor and your short-term
memory work client is electrical your
medium term memory will work fine that's
still doable because it doesn't require
a protein synthesis but your ability to
encode long term memories is compromised
people have a very high alcohol
tolerance can get into this mode they
call blackout drunk and a person can be
functional they're blacked out not
because they're unconscious but because
they're not encoding memories properly
and so you can actually have crazy
situations where you can write yourself
a letter or you could hide something
somewhere while you're under the
influence of this you wake up the next
day you actually genuinely surprise
yourself and communicate with yourself
this way
[Music]
you